meriem bonjour alors vous avez participé
à cette conférence de presse où en est
la procédure d'extradition
bonjour samantha j'ai suivi en effet
cette conférence de presse et j'ai
demandé à stella maurice la compagne de
julian assange ce qu'il en était de la
tête des états unis sur la décision de
non extradition
elle a répondu que la haute cour de
grande bretagne doit encore autoriser ou
non les états unis à faire appel ce
n'est pas encore fait nous sommes donc
en attente de cette décision at elle dit
il n'y a pas de délai fixé pour la
réponse quoi qu'il en soit le tribunal
pourrait dire qu'il rejette l'appel des
etats-unis et dans ce cas julian assange
pourra être remis en liberté et trouver
un endroit sûr où vivre dans le cas
contraire en revanche si l'appel est
autorisé il y aura alors de nouvelles
audiences probablement en automne ou
l'année prochaine et plus longtemps ils
y restent plus le risque est élevé qu'il
n'en sortent pas vivant selon sa
compagne lors de cette conférence de
presse qu'avez vous retenu des
interventions alors une grande
détermination de tous les intervenants
beaucoup de personnalités présentes
notamment nice melzer rapporteur spécial
de l'onu sur la torture
la maire de genève également frédéric
père l'air et jean rocio député vert à
l'origine d'une résolution du parlement
genevois demandant un visa humanitaire à
la suisse pour julian assange
christophe deloire également secrétaire
général de reporters sans frontières qui
a estimé qu' à travers le cas de julian
assange et bien c'était toute la
profession des journalistes et le droit
à l'information qui était menacée le
moment le plus marquant de cette
conférence a été
l'intervention de stella maurice la la
compagne de julian assange avec beaucoup
d'émotion au moment de parler de ces
enfants qui n'ont pas vu leur père
depuis plusieurs mois on écoute la
compagne de julian assange julian n'a
pas vu ses enfants depuis le mois
d'octobre
lorsqu'il a été emmené en prison la
dernière fois que je les ai vus c'était
au tribunal le 6 janvier dernier quand
sa remise en liberté sous caution a été
refusée
je ne dis pas aux enfants que leur père
est en prison
ils n'ont aucune idée de ce qu'est une
prison parce que quand j'essaie de leur
expliquer je dois dire que c'est là que
vont les criminels là où les gens
mauvais vont parce qu'ils ont fait de
mauvaises choses et non pas là où les
gens bien se rendre pour avoir fait de
bonnes choses
beaucoup d'émotion donc comme on a pu le
voir pour c'était la mort est soutenue
dans son combat par anonymele vers le
rapporteur spécial de l'onu sur la
torture ni le fr se bat depuis trois ans
pour la libération de julian assange
il a rappelé pour lui et donc ce cas est
un pur scandale et il a rappelé comment
lui même a été trompé sur la paire à
franges on écoute unilever
je suis allé voir julian assange après
que son premier avocat m'a contacté en
décembre 2018
il se trouvait encore à l'ambassade et
demander un mandat de protection ce que
j'ai refusé j'ai refusé intuitivement je
dis cela avec honte mais il est
important de le dire publiquement parce
que l'opinion publique mondiale pense
que julian assange est un hacker un
violeur un espion est un traître
j'avais été influencé par ses discours
des médias son sujet de façon
inconsciente au point que j'étais trop
aveugle pour voir la réalité en face
je n'aurais pas même pris en charge son
dossier jusqu'à ce que ses avocats
viennent une deuxième fois avec un
certain nombre de preuves qui m'ont
permis d'ouvrir les yeux
c'est ce qui m'a conduit à lui rendre
visite avec deux médecins spécialisés
qui dans l'examen des victimes de
torture avec une expérience de 30 ans
partout
monde sans être influencé par aucun
titre à scandale les deux médecins
indépendamment en sont venus à la même
conclusion julian assange présente tous
les symptômes de torture psychologique
et j'ai eu la même impression lorsque je
lui ai parlé
niels albert donc lui-même induit en
erreur dans un premier temps par le
récit médiatique sur la sphère assange
ils plaident eux pour qu'au minimum
julian assange soit mis en résidence
surveillée en attendant l'issue de la
procédure d'extradition
il a d'ailleurs à cet égard comparer son
cas le cas de julian assange à celui
d'augusto pinochet le dictateur chilien
car 1998 était sous le coup d'une
demande d'extradition de la part de
plusieurs états sauf que augusto
pinochet était donc on demandait son
écrin de son extradition cours
il était poursuivi pour crime de contre
l'humanité pour lui la seule raison pour
laquelle julian assange est maintenu en
prison c'est selon ronnie le meilleur la
seule raison pour laquelle tous les
instants j'ai maintenu en prison c'est
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas entendre
dire la vérité qu'il a à dire puisque
augusto pinochet poursuivi pour crimes
contre l'humanité avait pu lui bénéficié
d'une résidence surveillée dans une
ville là où il pouvait recevoir autant
de visiteurs qui le souhaitaient et
notamment l'ancienne première ministre
britannique margaret thatcher ce qui est
loin d'être plein assange
merci beaucoup à vous mairieelle malary
vie pour toutes ces précisions